[Music]
you mean just don't say it I gotta let
you go
you were just fired how many times but
listen to that low be firm the curse
than yours
well your brother's missing on all this
kind of stuff don't happen to normal
folk I'm sorry got some sort of robbery
to-do list
Shaun Motor Speedway it's the biggest
race in the year I know how they move
the money the only god knows about
blowing up bank vaults is Joe bang in
car sir ring and yeah we got play in the
kitchen where we're gonna Jensen saw
your daughter we need like a computer
whiz I know everything there is to know
about computers okay all the Twitter's I
know
you're going from secure location I'm
Colin own a phone like a real phone
let's blow this Bank you thought I was
gonna use a stick down a mountain yeah I
can to do it man me too
we are dealing with science fear the
system's gone down they're gonna know
what we want them to know don't want
everything I'm Jimmy Logan
something right I saw what I saw it's a
purple 77 over up I'm on my way to
church I don't have time for this step
out of the vehicle man I'm about to get
naked - no baby I said no bacon for you
my role is Logan curse just gossip you
moment must be as simple-minded as
people say people say that would you
give me my arm please
[Music]